krieg ohne ende endet auch unsere hilfe
irgendwann unsere unterstützung für die
ukraine bei uns der ukrainische
botschafter hier in deutschland andrej
melik der immer wieder gefordert hat von
uns allen uns zu engagieren uns endlich
ja mehr zu engagieren endlich die
versprochenen waffen zu liefern endlich
auch ein kanzler besuch in ihrem land zu
haben jetzt kündigt olaf scholz der
bundeskanzler genau das an für die jetzt
beginnende woche also der kanzler reist
mit frankreichs staatspräsident makro
und mit dem italienischen
ministerpräsidenten draghi zu ihnen ins
land was konkret soll kann muss dabei
rumkommen
herr kanzler hatte ja selbst gesagt er
braucht keine fototermine und auch wir
erwarten keine self ist da in kiew
sondern was wir oder was meine
landsleute hoffen ist dass dass der
kanzler einerseits mit einem klaren
bekenntnis zum thema
eu-mitgliedschaft nach kiew konnte und
endlich uns unterstützte um den
kandidatenstatus für diese
mitgliedschaft uns zu geben damit wird
auch ein langer weg beginnen für um
dieses zu erreichen das wir jahre dauern
wir wollten keine hintertüren
wir wollen ein faires aber auch ein ein
verfahren um
der eu beizutreten und das zweite
natürlich ist das thema waffen ich
glaube dass die erwartung in der ukraine
sehr hoch ist das wenn der kanzler da
ist zusammen mit den makro und draghi
das da wir endlich hören werden welche
waffen in deutschland zügig der
ukrainischen hat mehr liefern kann sie
sind teil der regierungsfraktion hören
sie schon was was dabei rumkommen wird
wird dass die eintrittskarte für die
europäische union seien die olaf scholz
dort mit seinen amtskollegen mitbringt
das entscheidet ja deutschland nicht
alleine sondern das wird europaweit
entschieden aber unsere aussenministerin
hat sich ja auch ganz klar dazu bekannt
und manche leute bringen das ja
durcheinander die denken dass die
ukraine dann sofort mitglied der
europäischen union ist sondern es geht
ja darum sie hätte gern den
kandidatenstatus das heißt das klare
bekenntnis
der europäischen union ihr seid ein
europäisches land ok heißt aber auch
mehr ist noch nicht also sagen ja ok
also wir ja auch schreiben da groß drauf
wir wollen das aber wir jagen den
deutschen da ganz so ernst ist ja nur
nicht nein liegt in weiter ferne liegt
das heißt nicht ganz so ernst ist es
nicht sondern das ist einfach ein langer
prozess wenn ich sie müssen das ganze
regularien der europäischen union
übernehmen und deshalb ist jetzt bei
allen ländern ein langer prozess aber
auch nicht wie im moment ne ne wir
können halt sagen uns auch nicht
wirklich dass sogar eine große
bereicherung wenn irgendwann die ukraine
mitglied wäre für
in der eu zu haben das muss man schon
offen aussprechen das ist natürlich es
geht die eu massiv es geht darum dass
hoffentlich bis dahin ja wieder krieg
beendet ist wir es geht uns ja darum die
ukraine ist so zu unterstützen dass sie
in der lage ist die kosten für russland
so hoch zu machen dass russland
möglichst schnell diesen krieg beendet
und dann geht es darum dass dann die
ukraine beitritt nämlich so ein prozess
dauert wenn es ganz schnell geht
5 78 jahre häufig länger als zehn jahre
weil es einfach ein riesen aufwand auch
für so ein landes aber es gibt auch
riesen vorteil man ist dann mitglied
eines der größten binnenmärkte der welt
und man hat natürlich auch einen
gewissen schutz also der kanzler reist
in die ukraine jetzt endlich sagt der
melnik endlich sagt auch herr hofreiter
der das viel früher auch schon getan hat
frau lindemann würden sie sich wünschen
dass der kanzler direkt danach bei ihnen
vorbeikommt in schwedt vorbeischaut
tatsächlich nicht aber
nicht sehen möchte ich jetzt sagen sie
sagen dran lastet acht bis zehn jahre
dauert bis die ukraine in der eu ist und
so lange dauert mindestens bis wir
umstellen können auf erneuerbare
energien sie müssen uns diese zeit auch
geben wir können dich in sechs monaten
unsere raffinerie die nur aus öl also
nur durch öl arbeitet auf immer zu einer
wasserstoff anlage machen geht und sechs
monaten nicht wir bräuchten auch zehn
monate und
jahre zehn jahre ich freude daran will
ich gar nicht sagen aber eigentlich
bräuchten wir diese zeit wir bräuchten
zehn jahre und stück für stück uns von
diesem roten zu verabschieden ist eine
möglichkeit das funktioniert mit
sicherheit aber wir bräuchten eben zeit
viel zeit um die ganzen anderen umbauen
zugesagt vor den nummern ich möchte euch
noch immer die nasa die zuschauer sei
jetzt kommt frau lindemann arbeitet seit
27 jahren in dieser raffinerie für sie
ist das ihr leben ihr berufliches leben
aber noch darüber hinaus seit immer
schon in schwedt für ihre söhne sollte
das auch ihr leben werden sie haben
immer gesagt mensch die sind jetzt
mittlerweile 16 die werden auch
irgendwann dort bei pck arbeiten das ist
ein toller arbeitgeber mittlerweile
ungewisse zukunft ungewisse zukunft
jahren jetzt wollte ich noch mal zu
meinem arbeitgeber sagen wir hätten die
chance unseren standort werden wir
finanzen bekommen ja vom bund oder von
den ländern und die zeit bekommen wir
wirtschaften daraus einen supertollen
standort zu machen der wirklich alle
fantasien sprengt wir könnten als
vorzeige standort dienen für umrüstung
von rohöl von fossilen brennstoffen auf
erneuerbare energien bleiben wir die
zeit hätten aber in sechs monaten
ruinieren werde diesen standort ja es
ist ein missverständnis es geht bei den
sechs monaten nicht darum dass die auf
komplett wasserstoff umstellen es geht
da ja warum das sein dass die es ist
kein beispiel sei es geht konkret um
schwedt jetzt es geht darum dass dann
schwedt aus rostock und aus danzig
sorgten aber auch öl genau
das ist der punkt
und es geht nicht darum dass die in
sechs monaten auf wasserstoff umstellen
sein sondern dass wir auch für ein
russisches rohöl zu kaufen und hole von
woanders zu kaufen und die umstellung
auf wasserstoff ist für viel länger
geplant also trauen sie sich keine
sorgen machen sie das ist wie gesagt
einfach ein missverständnis
holen hat und
sie sichern im grunde den arbeitsplatz
hat sie würden jetzt in dieser runde ist
fällt nicht ganz in ihre zuständigkeit
aber würden sagen im moment sieht alles
danach aus dass von lindemann den job
behält und jetzt mal ganz reines
gewissen sich machen kann und sie von
putins öl verabschieden kann polen hat
uns versprochen dass sie über danzig
gibt es eine pipeline hohen liefern das
kann angeliefert werden dann über
rostock kann angeliefert werden nämlich
die pipeline die das versorgt ist die
sogenannte druschba den inzwischen
zynischen namen freundschaft übersetzt
trägt die ist schon öfter stillgestanden
legen verschmutzung und dann ist die
raffinerie auch von woanders finanziert
werden zum beispiel im frühjahr 2009 10
ist die rohöl wegen chlorid ist die
pipeline chlorid verschmutzung ich
glaube drei monate still gestanden also
das ist nicht so unmöglich ist
augenscheinlich es wird und dann hat es
wie gesagt auch noch die möglichkeit
zusätzlich mit kesselwagen zu
unterstützen wo sowieso die preise schon
explodieren wir erleben einen natürlich
steigen die preise auch in der praxis
hat es damals aber die jahr 2009 und man
dafür einzelne vergessen ich mein für
uns geht es darum dass die preise etwas
höher werden da muss man gott menschen
mit geringem einkommen helfen aber für
die menschen in der ukraine geht es
darum das ist scheiße punkt was wir das
geld liefern mit dem putin krieg front
setzt das ist das rein und der häuser
und ihrer auswirkung gehört dann nicht
zu der ehrlichkeit hier an diesem tisch
dass sie frau lindemann sagen dann
müssen sie auf ihren job leider
verzichten weil es im moment etwas
wichtigeres gibt als die jobs dort
entsteht deswegen bemüht sich das
wirtschaftsministerium mit alles was ich
hat
einen ersatz zu finden für schwedt
nämlich die lieferung aus danzig
deswegen verhandeln mal mit polen war es
nicht einfach als und die lieferungen
als rostock aber nur noch mal ich will
will auf das thema sie haben ja nicht
die möglichkeit die welt zu retten
sondern sie müssen im moment prioritäten
setzen ist die priorität im moment dass
man der ukraine hilft und damit unseren
frieden unserer sicherheit dient und
eben damit der wirtschaft und den jobs
unter anderem in schwedt eben schade das
muss man doch dann offen auf den tisch
legen er natürlich schadet uns das etwas
aber danach ist
langfristig schadet uns noch viel mehr
wenn wir am ende sozusagen als die
dastehen die aus kurzfristigen
ökonomischen interessen ein
demokratisches nachbarland einer
diktatur zum fraß vor aber das ist das
ist die ehrliche diskussion dann auch zu
sagen wir müssen auf diese arbeitsplätze
möglicherweise verzichten das müssen in
deutschland herr malick den jährlichen
auch sagen nie ehrlicherweise muss man
sagen dass sie unter umständen auf noch
mehr arbeitsplätze
wenn wir sozusagen am ende als die
dastehen die auf der falschen seite oder
der minister
also ich versteh ganz gut da so ihre
sorgen dass auf ihren arbeitsplatz aber
ich kann ihnen nur sagen wo sie leben
sie sehe sie haben das glück in einem
stadtnahen ein sozialstaat zu leben das
heißt auch wenn der arbeitsplatz
verloren es gibt es kurzarbeit es gibt
viele instrumente wo sie oder andere
deutsche die betroffen sein werden
unterstützung bekommen das größte die
größte ölraffinerie in der ukraine die
computer wurde zerbombt in den ersten
kriegstagen und es war die 1000 fr
garantieren lassen sich auch an greift
einfach damit sie haben ein stück
verstehen wir leben leider auf anderen
planeten und was ich sagen wollte es
geht darum dass wenn der ukraine heute
geholfen wird das hat einen preis das
hat das haben auch viele politiker
gesagt also wir sind bereit auch diesen
preis mit zu tragen und damit für friede
eintritt und das liegt letztendlich auch
im deutschen interesse
wenn putin in der ukraine gestoppt wird
und nicht weiter den appetit auf seine
feldzüge bekommt und da ist nicht nur
polen oder baltikum länder sondern das
ist auch deutschland betroffen denn er
möchte sie haben die länder ins reich
wollen und er hat ja interessen zu viele
jahre verbrachte um aus deutschland
nicht als nicht für seine russische
heimat ja
nicht so also ich denke wir können alle
die politik
richtig kennt ja jeder ist ja inzwischen
auch noch ist das objekt unter möchte
für das erste mal kommen mit und band
also ich glaube wir haben von denen wir
haben in sachsen sehr lange und immer
wieder und das glaube ich auch zu recht
zurecht darauf gedrängt dass die
beziehung zu russland stabil bleiben das
war auch in zeiten so als russland nicht
gerne gesehen war das haben wir gemacht
indem wir zum beispiel young rooney das
eingeladen haben wir haben über
biologische fragestellungen gesprochen
rohstoffe andere sachen konferenzen
gemacht der hat schon mal unser
ministerpräsident wird dafür auch sehr
angegriffen zurzeit ich halte das
trotzdem für richtig wenn wir eine
oberste diplomatin haben deren aufgabe
und rolle es ist dafür zu sorgen dass er
mit jedem gesprächsfähig bleibt und wir
haben ja als deutschland sogar mit den
taliban angesprochen dann ist die frage
schon offen warum es auf einmal nicht
mehr möglich ist mit putin zu sprechen
dass der eigene pläne hat wird aus dem
kundigen meinhold von lindemann sieht
aber gerade gesagt sie haben eine
ernsthafte sorge dass wenn man die namen
ob soll schon da wird auch schon da war
die nato nicht eingreifen nein überhaupt
nicht ich sag nur vielleicht dann hätte
man ja mal im hinterkopf hat ist ja ja
ja aus st
er hat persönlich gesagt wir wollen
immer also sie haben diese angst sie
spüren diese angst ich könnte mir
durchaus vorstellen
also ich bin kann ich mir vorstellen
dass er das machen könnte ja warum
sollte er es nicht tun und wenn er immer
von diesem aggressor spricht warum warum
glaubt er nicht dass ja auch unser land
angreifen könnte ja ist ja das
schlimmste mensch aller zeiten und da
bin ich jetzt warum reden wenn ich mit
ihm warum reden wir nicht mit herrn
putin und was soll ich den taliban
schwer den tag jahren wurde verhandelt
das muss nicht mal vorstellen ich
verstehe auch ich es gab aber die szene
im letzten jahr alles in weiß rosa
grenze flüchtlinge aus verschiedenen
ländern standen und provoziert haben und
die polen haben dann reagiert wie ich
finde völlig zurecht und richtig und
dann hat putin mal in so einer kleinen
synthese nebenbei gesagt wenn das die
deutschen stört dann können sie haben
mal mit dem herrn lukaschenko reden mit
den taliban reden sie ja auch das habe
ich das zitat heute eingebracht
ich würde sagen da gibt es also ob das
eine rolle spielt oder nicht weiß ich
gar nicht aber ein gefühl einer
ungleichbehandlung weil wir natürlich in
rot alleine scholz telefoniert ja
permanent den
letzten monaten ist das anders geworden
ist war er vom letzten heizgeräte ich
bin nur deutlich machen es gibt
offensichtlich seit jahrzehnten
aufgestellt ein gefühl dass es nicht so
läuft wie man sich das denken dann
greift man auf imperiale sachen zurück
wir wollen mich freundlich den hut ein
putin hat damals ist doch absurd
sozusagen alles sprechen aber mal in
berlin greift die ukraine ab weil ich
genug mit ihm geredet worden ist die
ganze zeit nein am gerät immer anfrage
der sicherheitsarchitektur und da hat
sich europa nicht mehr die frage war
doch liebe parteien am ruder ist in den
ersten 16 jahre mit ihm auch eine liebe
die er sonst selten das führt jetzt halt
jeder um das ist
von herrn putin um das ja das ist
in dresden dass der sturm am erzählen
lassen von denen die dabei waren hat
putin mittel maschinengewehr draußen
gestand nun hat gesagt das ist
russisches staatsgebiet wenn sie das
betreten dann erschieße ich sie das
heißt der mann war schon immer so und
das ist und das und das russische
imperiales selbstverständnis war auch
schon immer so man möchte sich
vielleicht mal kulturell innerhalb
europas auf unterschiedliche
mentalitäten aber so lassen sich die
andrae zerbombten sie lassen einig dass
man dort wohl ich habe sich mario pohl
schaffen und und sagen dann und jetzt
setzt sich weiter das ist ja auch sie
wollen haltung ist eine creme aktion wie
aus der land mit dem verweis in meiner
kleinen aktion war klar dass wenn die
krim in den händen der größten bleibt
die den landweg suchen wollen um die zu
versuchen aber tatsächlich an wichtige
die
schuld zu doch nicht die richtige wäre
ist heute abend über die schuld wir sind
darüber hinaus schon naja hier haben wir
die hat die tragen die deutschen sehr
wohl die haben das sehr wohl aufgenommen
an den die zuschauer die sind sich sehr
wohl dessen bewusst dass sie uns die
schuld zuweisen für den krieg und sie
verteidigen natürlich das land beide
nicht da nicht ganz wahr sondern der der
regierungen dieses jahr werde die welt
weiter der deutsche kleidung trägt die
schuld dafür dass sie so abhängig sind
vom öl deswegen das tut mir leid dass
ihr arbeitsplatz
gefährdet ist aber wir haben nichts
dafür dass
es um die frage von denen wir uns
aber dass man einfach schuldig hat die
wahl sehen wo sie ganz kurz
privatschulen wir waren ein
deutschlandweiter wir waren schon einen
schritt weiter wir haben nämlich nicht
nur in die vergangenheit geschaut
sondern wir haben darüber diskutiert wie
kommen wir weiter wie beenden wir diese
reden und müssen jetzt unterricht diesen
dissens an diesem tisch und jetzt sind
wir bei den konkreten frage wie hat man
überhaupt mit putin reden so das was bei
rauskommt was ist denn die er wahlweise
mit dem verhalten war der amerikaner er
kann auch mit dem rüssel reden nein das
was das problem ist eher ob er das ernst
haben die europäer werden von putin
nicht absolut unschuldig aber das liegt
ja in der hand der europäer ich habe es
mehrmals darauf verwiesen hatte man
hätte bei der krim bereits anfangen
müssen zu intervenieren das nicht
zuzulassen dass es versäumt worden damit
ist natürlich für boutique auf den mund
legen ja kann machen was er will ich es
gab die diskussion im don pass und in
lugano war es auch das ist klar